[Music]
good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight as the Brett Kavanaugh
saga has just reminded us the left feels
no compunction about rooting around in
the pasts of people they don't like and
using what they find to destroy them the
question is do they apply the same
standard to themselves well tonight we
have breaking news about the past of a
well-known progressive and once again
confirms that no the standards are not
the same we'll bring that to you in just
a minute but first tonight here's a
quick quiz what exactly do you know
about Kamla Harris can you name three
things she believes then he named a
single thing she's accomplished if
you're like most Americans you cannot
you have no real idea who Kamla Harris
is the one thing you know about Harris
is that she could very easily become the
President of the United States and you
know this because you've been told it
confidently again and again by the
geniuses on television the name I'm
hearing now is that there was a she the
people sort of survey of prominent women
in politics number one name of some of
people of the person that's on people's
minds Connell Harris and the politician
she reminded me of most then was Barack
Obama Connell Harris is now running for
president and she is one of the top tier
candidates there's a new challenger to
trump and she's drawing huge crowds
senator Kamala Harris in California
kicked off her campaign this weekend
serenity I look at that crowd Trump must
be envious as hell , Harris is probably
somebody that on paper has the highest
ceiling you can envision a path for
Kamala Harris that quite resembles
Barack Obama's every word a cliche these
people are so stupid
it's remarkable they can breathe unaided
much less have paying jobs but whatever
the story they tell you Kendall Harris
he's a star destined for big things
she's like Obama to point out even more
woke with even more diversity points out
there in America they love Kamla Harris
she's a folk hero she's like Pete Seeger
for eight months they tried to cram that
story down your throat
time's it looked almost semi plausible
if you closed one eye during the first
wave of primary debates for example
Harris took a swing at the front-runner
she did announce Joe Biden as a racist
for having doubts about school busing it
later emerged that Harris herself that
had doubts about school busing in fact
almost no African American family in
America has supported school busing it
was a disaster Washington Post rushed to
a rescue quote Kamel Harris's takedown
of Joe Biden was more brutal than it
seems read the headline
yeah brutal she just dominated the guy
so ludicrous it turns out she didn't
actually dominate anybody and she's not
dominating anybody a new poll from
California obviously of her home state
which she represents in the United
States Senate shows Harris way at the
back of the pack she's now dropped into
fifth place
she's polling at 6% how bad is that well
here's some perspective as of today
kammo Harris is losing to Andrew yang
the anti-circumcision candidate and by
the way she ought to be losing to Andrew
Yang whatever you think of Yang's ideas
Andrew yang is smart he's original he's
totally genuine Harris is the opposite
Harris is a soulless corporate shill it
was an utter to single authentic word
since she entered public life
Harris by the way is the daughter of a
Stanford professor which is great good
for her and yet she somehow pretends she
overcame segregation right
I still see Gabbard pointed out Harris
is also a former prosecutor she put
others in jail for marijuana but she now
brags about smoking weed herself and
listening to rap cos she's cool in other
words Harris embodies everything that is
grating and unlikable about Neal
liberals mindless children of privilege
who sneer at those below them for not
obeying turns out even a lot of faithful
Democratic voters find the whole thing
totally unbearable because it is
unbearable I mean really
mercifully it looks like the camel
Harris campaign is doomed to dry up and
blow away and that can't come too soon
even the press appears to have abandoned
her their new crush senator Elizabeth
Warren in Massachusetts how
consequential was that rally last night
not just what she said but the four
hours of selfies afterward
we are just learning the senator took
some 4000 selfies for hours taking
selfies who's out there taking selfies
the people waited for hours there to
take selfies she spent four hours taking
selfies four thousand last night that's
remarkable yeah four thousand last night
the campaign says fifty nine thousand
since she has started running for
president some people waited for hours
to have a selfie taken oh they're in
love
warned that telling you is a rising star
and actually that's true
she's in fact the front-runner in the
Democratic race technically Joe Biden is
polling in first place but nobody
expects that to last even Jimmy Carter
has given up on Joe Biden watch this you
know if I were just 80 years old I don't
believe I could undertake the duties
that I experienced when I was president
but one thing you had to be very
flexible with your mind you had to be
able to go from one subject to another
and concentrate on each one adequately
you have to be able to concentrate
unlike Joe Biden not a subtle dig
Elizabeth Warren by the way would be
over 75 years old she's elected
president by the end of her first term
and yet she would still be way younger
than Joe Biden or Bernie Sanders so as
of tonight it looks like Elizabeth
Warren by default but who knows now that
the press has anointed her Warren may be
doomed to that's never a good sign